If you have gestational diabetes during your pregnancy
the level of sugar in your bloodstream is higher than normal.
The sugar in your blood is called glucose.
A hormone in your body called insulin
acts like a key in a lock
when it attaches to receptors on your cells.
The insulin opens your cells
so glucose can enter them.
Now your cells can use the glucose
to produce the energy they need
to function properly.
A gland called the pancreas makes all the
insulin your cells need to use glucose.
The exact cause of gestational diabetes isn't known.
However, the organ that attaches your baby
to your uterus, called the placenta,
makes hormones that may prevent insulin
from letting glucose into your cells.
As a result the glucose in your blood
rises above normal levels
in a condition called hyperglycemia.
Hyperglycemia is the hallmark
of any type of diabetes.
If your blood glucose levels are not
kept in the normal range
you may develop complications
such as high blood pressure.
In addition you have an increased risk
for premature birth.
and cesarean birth, in which your doctor
delivers your baby
through an incision in your abdomen.
Your baby may also be at risk
for complications shortly after birth including
excessive birth-weight, called macrosomia
low blood sugar, called hypoglycemia
a yellow color of your baby's skin,
called jaundice
and difficulty breathing.
Gestational diabetes usually goes away
after your baby is born
The goal of treating gestational diabetes
is to keep your blood glucose
in your normal target range.
You can do this by creating a healthy
eating plan with your health care provider
or a registered dietitian.
Physical activity and exercise can
also help you keep your blood glucose level
within your normal target range.
Your doctor may ask you to regularly
check your blood glucose level
with a glucose meter.
To check your blood glucose level you
will insert a test strip
into your glucose meter.
Then you will stick your finger and
place a drop of blood
onto the test strip.
The glucose meter will measure and
display your blood glucose level.
If you have gestational diabetes the
American Diabetes Association
recommends the following target ranges
for blood glucose level:
95 or less before a meal
140 or less one hour after a meal
and 120 or less two hours after a meal
Check with your doctor for your specific
target range.
If diet and exercise are not able to
keep your blood glucose level within
your normal target range
your caregiver may prescribe
insulin for you,
and show you how to give
yourself insulin shots.
You can help prevent
gestational diabetes by
getting preconceptual counseling in
which you meet with your obstetrician
before you get pregnant to plan a
healthy pregnancy,
losing excess pounds before you get
pregnant,
getting regular exercise before and
during your pregnancy,
and eating healthy foods.